hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about seven effective ways to beat
stress and as always guys if you hear a
point that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well and also writing it
down helps you lock it in for yourself
to enjoy so we need an entrepreneur is
one of the most stressful things I think
you can do in your life it's gonna be
one of the hardest things you will ever
do in your life it's a start of business
I don't think enough people talked about
the difficulties associated with it
this is a reason why 80 to 90 percent of
companies fail because it's stressful
because it's hard it sucks there's a lot
that goes into building a company that
we just don't talk enough about and I
think entrepreneurs are among the most
stressed out people in the world and
listen we're trying to do big bold
empowering exciting things and so I'm
gonna share with you seven ways that I
hope will effectively beat the stress
for you some of the things we can do
immediately some of the things that will
work over a longer period of time as
well and I hope you enjoy the video so
way number one is ask yourself does this
matter it's surprising how much of the
stuff that we put on our plate every
single day doesn't actually matter and
the things that we stress about are so
little and so tiny that in the big
picture they don't actually matter and
so when you're in the stressful zone the
the hardest thing to do is just step
outside and look at yourself look at
yourself and say that thing that I'm
worrying about does it actually matter
and more often that you'll come back
with I know like this actually doesn't
matter and I'm being stressed out for no
reason and it's gonna work out in a big
picture so as an example I have
mastermind groups in Toronto and I used
to keep meeting minutes I used to keep
notes on what happened in the meetings
and I would email it to everybody after
each session it took me a while to put
the notes together a summary I thought
it was a value I'd service right
everyone keeps preaching add value I
thought this was adding a lot of value
to people's lives and it would stress me
out always to take notes as quick as I
could
and then send it off to people as fast
as I could and there was one time then
when I just didn't have the time I was
stressed out I had too much stuff
happening I didn't
had the time to send notes out to people
and you know what happened nothing
nothing happened nobody cared nobody
wrote to me and said where the notes
were the minutes and then the next month
I didn't do it again nobody cared I was
doing all this work and stressing myself
out over something that didn't matter
nobody actually cared about it I
convinced myself that it was important
but it actually wasn't important and so
thinking about the things that stress
you out how much are they really part of
the big picture where you see yourself
going because this thing actually really
matter
usually it's no and just that awareness
just asking that question can
immediately help reduce the stress way
number two to effectively reduce stress
is come back to tomorrow sometimes I
find that if I'm in the moment and I'm
stressed out and I'm angry or agitated
and and you know I'm not thinking
clearly sometimes the best thing to do
is just to leave it go to something else
and come back to it the next day and the
next day you come back to it and your
mind is fresh and you're in a different
headspace and it just the answer comes
to you and so I find that if I'm ever
struggling on something I just I'm not
getting through I'm not getting an
answer just push it off come it's not
like push it off forever unless it's not
important but coming back to it the next
day I find often I come with a solution
that comes superfast and I just saved a
lot of time because now wasn't spending
hours and hours and hours frustrated
trying to figure out a problem we number
three to reduce stress is finish it now
now this may seem counterintuitive and
the opposite of what I just talked about
and finish it tomorrow and I think the
context really is if you have an answer
so if I'm stressed out but I know what
to do then I will find it easier to get
it done right now if I don't know what
to do if I'm frustrated and stressed
because I don't have an answer then you
can leave it for the next day and so if
you have a clear answer you know what
used to get done then you just up
against the deadline just get it done
what I'll find is if if I know what
needs to get done and I'm delaying it
and I'm waiting till tomorrow then I'm
spending all that time thinking about it
like I just need to get this done I just
need to get this and then you're not
enjoying the rest of your day you're not
present in any of your other meetings or
home with your family you just always
just stressed out thinking about it so
if you have a
clear solution then deal with it
immediately if you don't know what to do
next
then you can wait push it off to
tomorrow and come back to when you have
a fresh mind we number four is model
success one of the things that really
helped me and my first business got me
through the most stressful part of my
life really was understanding that I
wasn't the first person to try to solve
this problem before you know when I told
my business partner that I quit and I
wanted to leave the company and then
hearing me say those words just stress
me out and I knew the next day that I
had to go back and do this I couldn't
quit on this I had to find a way to keep
going but I had to find a different way
to stand and the realization of hitting
rock bottom
the realisation that came to me was that
somebody else had figured this out
before whatever thing you're stressed
out about right now whatever problem
you're faced and it seems insurmountable
that is impossible to overcome many many
many people have already figured it out
many people it's one of the founding
reasons for why I created this youtube
channel was to share the strategies of
successful entrepreneurs and it's from
two angles
one the strategy is like what do I do
I'm facing this problem here's a
solution every time I watch one of the
top ten videos are meant to me videos
are believed like videos I learned
something I learned a new strategy that
I can apply to my life or to my business
even if I've heard it before sometimes
it comes from a different voice a
different angle and I see a slightly
different way than I can apply it the
second thing it does so it also gives
you just motivation just for me knowing
that I'm not the only person in the
world who's ever gone through this you
know seeing other entrepreneurs have
hard times and fail and struggle made me
feel like this is normal like what I'm
dealing with is normal and if they can
get through it like I can get through it
too a lot of these people started with
less than what you already have right
now you already have more money more
resources more connections more
opportunities than a lot of these
successful entrepreneurs had when they
started you are starting with more than
what they had and so I would tell myself
listen if they could do it why can't I
they don't have any natural advantage if
they can do it I can get it too and so
by modeling success one to figure out
the specific strategies and tactics
things that I can apply but also just to
motivate
to know that these successful people
went through the same thing I was that
dramatically help me reduce my stress
[Music]
number five is join or start a
mastermind group I think one of the
biggest challenges of being an
entrepreneur is that you're alone you
know you don't have other entrepreneurs
to talk to so many entrepreneurs that I
connect with and meet they're the only
entrepreneurs in their circle they're
family they're not entrepreneurs their
friends are not entrepreneurs
everybody's telling them that they're
crazy they should do the safe thing and
stay with their job and they should take
a you know professional career and and
sometimes you know those people around
you are hating on you but sometimes it's
just out of love the way that they see
success is a normal typical corporate
career and that's not what you want and
so when you don't have people around you
who are like-minded in that capacity it
can be really hard to move forward and
it's easy to get stressed out and so I
find that being a part of a mastermind
group if there's one in your area where
you could join an online one we have an
online one or you can start your own
where you're connecting with like-minded
people a lot of the people in my group
call it entrepreneurs Anonymous because
half of it is about strategies and
tactics and here's the problem I'm
facing what do you guys think do you
have connections or ideas to help me and
half of it it's just about having people
around you who understand you you know
coming to a monthly meeting where you're
connected to people who get what you're
going through who have gone through it
who are facing some of the same
challenges and just that emotional
support so being a part of a mastermind
group again from the strategies and from
the emotional side can dramatically help
reduce your stress
[Music]
the sixth way to reduce your stress is
to create a better schedule I live and
die by my schedule I find that if I
don't have it scheduled in and I don't
have a plot somewhere in my week to deal
with something then I get stressed out I
get antsy I get nervous like what am I
gonna do it I forced myself to do it now
and it may not always be the best time
to do it
this happens maybe once a quarter on a
big scale maybe once a month on a
smaller scale where just something
happens in my life or in my business or
just I want to grow and I want to learn
something else and to do it I need to
take time from somewhere else and
recognize your time is limited you only
have so many hours in a week you have
other interests as well and so if you
want to add something to it you have to
take something away when I took over
China dance also and acquired the
business last year I knew it would take
up a lot of my time and so I had to
dedicate a single day in the week so
Tuesday's as my turnitin sells a day all
day I'm working on TBS stuff I'm working
with Alex I'm mentoring them training
doing all the stuff that needs to get
done to build and grow this business it
also means that I'm out three nights a
week in coming to class and having
meetings and going to parties and
entertaining and hosting and so it's a
big time committed to be prepared for
and so while I was talking to my wife
Nina and saying here's what I'm thinking
of doing and getting her support that
this is something that I'm committed to
and - in order for me to free up a
Tuesday I had other stuff planned on
that Tuesday great I had to take away
some other things to say you know what
this is not as important a priority and
I think too many times we just jam our
schedule or we don't have any any kind
of plan for our schedule we just get it
filled up with things and then when you
want to add something new to it you
can't because it's jammed full and so
whenever I feel stressed out about
something and it's consistent like every
week I'm feeling stressed out about
something I know that I need to make
more time for it in my calendar and see
if I can find a way to schedule that in
so that I would be less stressed every
week
[Music]
and the number seven effective way to
beat stress is to get some help you know
you can't do everything yourself in your
business and you're likely doing things
that you shouldn't be doing and so I
mentioned earlier on that I used to take
meeting notes and it wasn't effective
and I should have stopped doing that a
lot earlier that's not something that
you want to get help on that's just
something you wanted luminate first rule
is eliminate look at where you're
spending your time and eliminate the
things that are not adding the most
value when you're especially the early
stage of the business and everything is
you you need to really focus your time
because you're everything from the CEO
to the janitor in your business and so
you need to make sure that the time
you're spending is having the most
impact possible and you're eliminating
the things that you don't want to be
great at so eliminate is number one
automate is number two look at the tasks
that you're doing if anything is
happening consistently that should be
automated you shouldn't go to somebody
else it should just be automated should
go to a software program a computer
system a website right making something
so that there's these tools that
automate things for you can really free
up your time because those tools you
know they don't take sick days they
don't require vacation pay they're a lot
cheaper than having somebody working for
you and so eliminate his first automate
a second and the third is delegate if
you're doing something important you
have to build a team the first person I
hired was for one hour a day and he
freed up more than an hour of my time of
day because he was better at the work
than I was and then I slowly built up my
team and so you can hire somebody may
not have enough money to have somebody
come on full-time in your business but
to hire somebody for an hour a day or a
couple hours a week to help take off
some of the tasks that you shouldn't be
doing will really help you want to spend
as much time when the CEO role as
possible that's where you want to be and
so looking at your schedule I've seen
where am i spending time that should be
eliminated what things can be automated
and then whatever is left that still has
to get done how do I delegate some of
these other things so that I can focus
on what I'm great at so when I started
my youtube channel I did everything
myself I'm a big advocate of not
spending money till you're making money
don't go and start hiring somebody if
you're making zero in your business but
as soon as I started making money on my
youtube channel you know I was doing
everything I was a cameraman I was the
editor was the researcher I was in front
of the camera everything
as soon as it started make it fun on our
YouTube channel I poured a back in and
the first person I hired was an editor
because editing took me a long time I
wasn't very good at it I didn't want to
get good at it more importantly and then
as I started making more I hired more
people more editors a cameraman I bought
more gear I got you know I got cameras I
got microphones you know I got
researchers I got people to help me on
the YouTube channel with the comments
and so my team grew as my business grew
but the thing that really helps
skyrocket the early growth was getting
my first editor so as soon as you can
afford it bringing somebody on to help
alleviate some of the tasks you're not
good at and more importantly don't want
to get good at either can really help
you quickly scale up your business and
reduce the stress because you get most
stressed out when you're doing work that
you don't want to do so those are my
seven ways to effectively reduce stress
I'd love to know what did you think
which way resonated the most with you do
you have an 8 9 10 that you want to add
to the list leave it down in the
comments below super curious to find out
what you have to say I also want to give
a quick shout out to John Simon's thank
you so much John for picking up a copy
of my book I really really really
appreciate it and if your doing that
review means a lot to me man and I'm
glad you enjoyed the book so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon